alors trois insolites au programme on
demandera nos invités quelle information
à retenir leur attention on va commencer
avec une séance de cinéma pas comme les
autres Véronique une séance karaoké
exactement alors c'est Samy squelette
chic et le directeur adjoint du l'UGC
Reno qui est à l'initiative de cet
événement il nous propose de nous de
nous retrouver au sirènes à Versailles
donc vendredi 23 juin pour un karaoké
autour du
biopico
voilà alors comment ça va se passer au
début vous pouvez venir déguiser aussi
en freining Mercury donc vous avez déjà
la moustache c'est déjà bien passé
la mienne on verra où j'en serai
vendredi et après vous arrivez donc
faire 19h mettons la grande c'est la
grande salle qui sera ouverte à 19h30
vous avez un animateur qui prend ma
soirée il y a des jeux des choses à
gagner et ceux qui gagnent ont le droit
de monter sur la scène pour chanter au
micro accompagné par la salle évidemment
après il y aura aussi le le meilleur
déguisement qui va être récompensé
pareil bon plein de choses très sympas
et très très rigolotes et après un petit
entracte et le film va démarrer en
version karaoké c'est à dire que dès
qu'il y aura un morceau chanté les
paroles apparaissent en gros pour que
tout le monde puisse s'époumonner en
coeur
il y a des titres iconiques exactement
et juste pour terminer leur si ça marche
ce qu'on espère parce que vraiment je
vous encourage à y aller ça va être très
chouette et ben on aura la même chose
pour les enfants en décembre voilà alors
on vous tiendra au courant pour cette
séance karaoké autour du film Bohemian
Rhapsody on va poursuivre avec une expo
photo d'une d'une artiste alors qui
pratique l'art mobile alors moi
personnellement je ne connais pas l'art
mobile non a priori non
c'est juste le terme en fait c'est un
art émergent qui émerge quand même
depuis 10 ans parce que c'est ça fait
depuis 10 ans qu'on peut prendre des
photos avec son smartphone et il se
trouve que Clarisse debout quand on fait
une photographe d'art elle habite depuis
3 ans à Versailles et le propose une
exposition de ses œuvres alors c'est
vraiment une exposition flash parce que
ça va durer sur tout samedi 24 juin à la
galerie font la fontaine au Carré
Saint-Louis à Versailles son Instagram
le dit tout de suite c'est Clarisse
debout je crois que j'ai dit claire tout
à l'heure peut-être
debout elle a un jour elle s'est
retrouvée en panne de d'appareils photos
déchargés donc elle a présenté téléphone
elle s'est rendu compte que ses photos
étaient intéressantes aussi avec un
grain différent que ça a apporté quelque
chose et en fait c'est un arc donc qui
existe depuis assez longtemps donc 10
ans surtout ça a démarré aux États-Unis
après au Canada après dans toute
l'Europe voilà et comment elle fait
alors elle prend ses photos elle prend
sa photo un peu au hasard en fait
différents dépité entre en jeu dans la
façon de d'exercer cet art c'est à dire
qu'on trouve quelque chose sans vraiment
l'avoir chercher quoi l'oeil du
photographe est attirer les TAC toc toc
voilà et donc elle prend sa photo elle
exerce un travail de retour après elle
mixe différentes applications qu'elle
utilise pour pour le résultat qu'elle
soit avoir après elle fait le même ses
tirages elle a une imprimante pro donc
elle choisit ses papiers en fonction du
grain des papiers plus ou moins épaisses
jouer aussi sur les transparences il y a
d'ailleurs je sais pas si je pense qu'on
la verrait une photo avec des cosmos
voilà on imagine complètement la
transparence et c'est ces œuvres en fait
des photos moi j'ai envie de dire
tableau il y a une ambiance une
atmosphère
complètement et c'est un peu ferry qui
réel on sait plus trop ce que enfin ça
peut être des lieux qu'on connaît mais
vu différemment vu qu'elle est un peu
novice à Versailles elle a un œil neuf
qu'elle nous apporte et c'est bien
agréable et qu'est-ce que j'ai oublié de
dire bah je pense que c'est tout oui
alors bizarrement presque bizarrement
cet art est très reconnu partout
ailleurs sauf en France on en parle pas
trop il y avait une galerie à Paris
spécialisée dans leur mobile et puis
elle a fermé et puis voilà et ça permet
aussi de désacraliser les œuvres d'art
parce que il y a le il y a internet
enfin les réseaux qui permettent de on
peut avoir une offre très connue sans
que l'auteur soit connu vous voyez c'est
pas comme idée je trouve voilà donc
Versailles autrement et c'est Versailles
autrement pour pour
galerie Lafontaine caresse Saint-Louis
voilà c'est des nouvelles de la lettre
de Charlotte Corday vous nous en aviez
parlé il y a quelques semaines sur le
plateau de TV 78 qui a été vendu aux
enchères avec un prix qui s'est envolé
complètement alors en fait
c'est la maison hausna à Versailles qui
qui a organisé cette vote aux enchères
c'est une lettre manuscrite de Charlotte
Corday que vous connaissez comme moi qui
est assassiné Mara et qui venait de sa
Normandie natale pour se faire pour elle
c'est un acte civil c'était voilà et la
mise a pris je sais pas si on dit ça
comme ça mais 70 000 € le prix de départ
voilà 70 000 euros et en fait c'est
monté jusque dans
270900 euros donc c'est quand même
énorme les enchères ont été assez longs
ça a duré 10 minutes par exemple c'est
long ou je peux très bien voilà pour des
enchères et Jean-Pierre au snail avait
estimé entre 80 et 100000 euros voilà
c'est le commissaire prisère Jean-Pierre
Rossin voilà et c'est une lettre qui est
quand même vieille de 230 ans et quoi
d'autre bah c'est la région Normandie
qu'il a acquise voilà puisque Charlotte
Corday était normande descendante
d'ailleurs de Pierre Corneille et son
geste elle dit qu'elle l'a elle a
pourquoi je trouve fumé mot moi c'est
grave il fait trop chaud
en fait c'est c'est au nom du respect
des lois de la paix civile voilà elle a
été guillotinée 17 juillet 1793 ça c'est
cadeau un petit peu historique ça peut
pas faire de mal voilà à peu près 29
degrés en plateau juste pour préciser
votre attention plus qu'une autre à moi
la première je veux aller au cinéma
j'ai adoré le film et j'adore les
chansons de Queen donc voilà juste
l'occasion de vendre l'utile à
l'agréable alors on vous retrouve aussi
Véronique en plus des insolites chaque
mardi à la présentation des Vy P very
ivunoise personnes qui mettent en avant
des personnalités du territoire qu'on
avait des prochains qui sont programmés
merci
de me relancer là-dessus demain faites
de la musique je reçois Garance tout
court qui est une chanteuse auteur
compositrice yvelinoise qui démarre sa
carrière qui va s'annoncer enfin qui
s'annonce qui s'annonce brillante et
elle sort à Neper et elle sera en
concert le 16 septembre au Palais des
Congrès de Versailles voilà merci
beaucoup Véronique mardi prochain merci
Grégory comme d'habitude pour pour les
ins